you or someone you care about may have
been recently diagnosed with bladder
cancer
this video will help you understand some
of the available treatment options
the most common type of bladder cancer
called urothelial carcinoma
or transitional cell carcinoma is a
disease
where cancer cells form in the tissue
lining the inside of the bladder
treatments for bladder cancer may
include one or more of the following
surgery radiation therapy chemotherapy
and immunotherapy there are two main
types of surgery for bladder cancer
the first type is called transurethral
resection of bladder tumor
or turbt with fulguration for early
stage cancer
during this procedure a lighted tube
called a cystoscope
will be inserted into your bladder
then the tumor will be removed with a
wire loop
remaining tumor tissue may be burned
away in a process called
folguration
the second type of surgery called
cystectomy is for cancer that has spread
into the bladder wall during a partial
cystectomy the part of your bladder wall
containing a small
tumor will be removed
after this type of surgery your
remaining bladder may not be able to
hold as much urine
you may need to urinate more often
in a radical cystectomy all of your
bladder will be removed if the tumor is
large
or is in more than one part of the
bladder nearby tissue
such as lymph nodes will also be removed
in men the prostate and seminal vesicles
will be removed
and in women the uterus ovaries
fallopian tubes and part of the vagina
will often be removed
if your bladder is removed a piece of
your intestine
can be used as a passageway for urine to
drain out of your body
it will drain through an opening in your
abdomen and into a small bag
or the intestine can be shaped into a
small pouch
to store the urine before it passes
through the opening in your abdomen
in this case you will put a small tube
called a catheter
into the opening to empty urine from the
pouch
or if your urethra was preserved a new
bladder can be built from a piece of
intestine so urine can pass out of your
body in the usual way
another treatment option is radiation
therapy
it uses radiation to kill the cancer
cells
or keep them from growing external beam
radiation
uses a machine outside the body that
aims radiation at the cancer
internal radiation therapy uses a
radioactive
source that gives off radiation the
radioactive source is put
inside the body into or near the cancer
chemotherapy uses certain drugs to kill
cancer cells or
stop their growth these drugs may be
administered
intravenously to treat cancer cells
throughout the whole body
or via a catheter to treat cancer cells
inside the bladder
the way the chemotherapy is administered
will depend on how advanced the bladder
cancer
is immunotherapy
helps your immune system fight cancer
cancer can sometimes
hide from the immune cells that attack
them
for example both cancer and immune cells
may have
proteins called checkpoint proteins if
these proteins attach
the immune cell won't attack the cancer
cell
some immunotherapy drugs for bladder
cancer block the checkpoint proteins
from attaching to each other
as a result the immune cell can attack
and destroy the cancer cell
another example of immunotherapy is
called
bcg it's made of a type of bacteria
in a solution
bcg is put inside your bladder where it
sets off a response
that kills cancer cells
if you have questions about bladder
cancer or any medications you have been
prescribed
talk to your doctor it is important to
take your medications as directed and
report any side effects you may have